what could the g7 do to stop the war in
ukraine leaders of the world's biggest
economies say that they're imposing more
sanctions on moscow but is that enough
and can the group remain united against
vladimir putin this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm adrian
finnegan four months of war in ukraine
have exposed deep divisions in the
global order but the fighting is also
highlighting and testing some of the
oldest and strongest alliances
the g7 a group of the world's seven
largest economies is meeting this week
in germany sanctions by some of its
members and counter sanctions from
russia have disrupted everything they've
touched from oil prices to supply chains
to the price of bread on the other side
of the world
under germany's presidency the g7 is
pushing for solutions to reduce the
impact of the war on the global economy
well g7 leaders issued a statement to
remove any doubt about their commitment
to keeve saying that they will continue
to provide financial humanitarian
military and diplomatic support and
stand with ukraine for as long as it
takes
they also announced targeted sanctions
on those responsible for war crimes or
exercising illegitimate authority in
ukraine
the statement added that russia bears
enormous responsibility for rising
threats to global food security as a
result of the conflict
china is also on the g7 summit agenda
600 billion dollars have been pledged to
counter beijing's belt and road
initiative and beijing has been quick to
respond
china welcomes all initiatives that
promote global infrastructure we believe
that there is not any initiative aimed
at replacing each other what we oppose
is to advance geopolitical calculations
and smear the belt and road initiative
in the name of promoting global
infrastructure development
so let's bring in our guests for today's
discussion from berlin we're joined by
ulrich brookner who's professor of
political science at stanford university
in berlin from washington dc doug bando
senior fellow at the cato institute and
from oslo glenn diesen professor of
international relations at the
university of southeast norway gentlemen
welcome to the program um ulrich let's
start with you so g7 leaders will stand
with ukraine for as long as it takes
as long as what takes what is it that g7
leaders want and how long is long
well all these questions have not been
answered yet what we saw was
a strong signal and that's the symbolism
of summits of that kind that sometimes
feel a bit like 20th century as if we
are not having phone calls or
zoom meetings so it's more like we send
a signal but we don't go into detail
because everyone is affected differently
from the sanctions and everyone also has
a different agenda or is more or less
careful with all the balances that need
to be considered
doug
what do you make of it
how long is long and and what is it that
g7 leaders actually want here
i don't think they even know clearly
perspectives differ in the different
capitals uh countries are affected
differently they have different past
relations with russia
they have a different i think
willingness to tolerate cost
as a in terms of where we're going
everyone would like to see russia to
lose but that doesn't necessarily mean a
victory for ukraine and in many ways i
think that is the biggest issue
is the emphasis going to be on trying to
reach some kind of a ceasefire in peace
or is the emphasis to help ukraine have
some kind of a military victory on that
we don't know and those outcomes are
very different and have a very different
implication for the cost and the length
of time
glenn
victory for ukraine
humiliation for for russia what is it
that g7 leaders are after
well that's kind of unclear because when
i talk about victory for ukraine what
does this mean
because at times ukraine has expressed
this interest in
in
reconquering all of donbass even taking
back crimea so this would
entail an actual war with russia and
again part of the russian motivation
behind this is obviously uh to stop the
nato expansionism and
it is this increasing
amount of american weapons system close
to this border so if russia would pull
out obviously this would uh
this weapons would only keep pouring in
so so
i'm not sure how that would how that
victory would be even possible i think
russia would fight this definitely uh
all the way to the end so um
and uh yeah so i i just don't
see uh see clearly how victory has been
conceptualized here
also it's unclear
how even a stalemate is going to result
in any kind of a
diplomatic solution because again
the fear from moscow then would be
obviously that the west will take
advantage of it a temporary peace
agreement to merely rearm ukraine and
keep pushing
nato so i it's very it's very it's a lot
of big statements but without any clear
uh operationalization of this a clear
objective what this would actually mean
all right so ulrich they put on this
united front as you say they made this
strong statement of support for ukraine
but what is actually going on behind
closed doors do you think how long
can their unity last given the economic
consequences of the war
well that's what i meant by the
different balances that need to be
considered
and
in my humble understanding of
what has been the motivation or the
objectives because i
clearly don't understand how putin ticks
there was a calculation that the west is
post heroic not willing to fight a war
not taking a risk we don't believe in
anything we are near list we
are secular and so as wimps as we are it
would be easy to go in and
to achieve objectives that make no sense
in terminology like
a denasification or whatever time
so what we have now is a united west a
much stronger nato and even extended
nato a stronger investment in rapid
intervention forces so basically the
opposite of what putin tried to achieve
but we also have a situation in which
all the different leaders face different
domestic pressure
some struggle more with inflation some
are more
dependent on
import
some are weaker than others when we look
at
the internal discussion about what is
their price to pay for expressing
solidarity or what can a leader push
through if we look for example at macaw
his position was way stronger before the
parliamentary elections a few days ago
and this is all something that needs to
be taken into consideration
doug who's leading the g7 right now okay
chancellor schultz is hosting uh this
meeting but but who's in the driving
seat as far as policy is concerned is
the us at the moment taking a back seat
and following the rest or is it actually
leading do you think at least in terms
of the war in ukraine
well in terms of the war i think the us
broadly speaking has driven the process
the u.s has contributed substantially
more in terms of money and weapons
it you know has the advantage of having
the real military you know that
dominates nato uh frankly the country
that most european countries have
cheerfully uh cheap ridden on
for decades
so there's an element of which the u.s
has a natural leadership role there
but you know it's not alone the other
countries matter and it matters a lot to
have other european countries
indicate they are prepared to do more
and we see even a country like turkey
can throw a spanner in the works over
the issue
of bringing in finland and sweden for
its own purposes
so there's leadership but there's not
domination i think that what we see
going forward has indicated macron has
his own domestic issues certainly
germany i mean a complicated political
situation a three-party government
bearing significant energy costs even in
the u.s the politics is not going to be
easy
outside of kind of washington you know
support for a deep commitment to ukraine
is not necessarily that strong i talk to
my non-political friends and they are
asking why 40 billion dollars when
that's a lot more than europe has done
why 40 billion dollars and we have a
trillion dollar deficit
and we see in the republican party
increasing willingness on the hard right
to ask questions about this so this is
going to be a very difficult process
going forward nothing is guaranteed
uh glenn
glenn the the the european union while
represented at this this summit uh
doesn't the g7 itself doesn't represent
all uh european nations how does the the
rest of europe minus the uk france and
italy view the war in ukraine
well i guess europe is very split in
many ways the western european countries
are more cautious while the countries
like poland and the baltic states
they're more hawkish more aligned with
the united states and the uk on this
matter
so i i would say that
initially i think we've had a lot of
unity because of
this innovation by russia took everyone
by surprise and the shock
which was why you have this common
interest in balancing this common
adversary but i do believe that uh a lot
of this um
unity was based on the premise that nato
would have a victory over russia or
um ukraine supported by nato uh but i
think
what you will see is not just a split
between the u.s and european but but
within europe as well you will see more
of these divisions
displaying themselves now that the
conflict is not going our way because
again russia is winning now on the
battlefield and the sanctions have
backfired terribly on the europeans so
it becomes therefore reasonable very
reasonable to more divisions within the
g7 uh so well for example i made an
argument that the us and the uk would
probably like to see this war going for
a while because it has many good
objectives for the us so it imposes
block discipline within the west which
the u.s has not been previously able to
achieve
the u.s has been able to get the
europeans to decouple from russian
energy and economy which they didn't do
in the past
uh we also see that the u.s can now
extend this european divorce to china so
ukraine will be a bulwark against russia
for the foreseeable future and
the u.s has this opportunity of making
ukraine afghanistan for the russians to
blade drives economy and its military so
it has many opportunities for the us but
that's what i mean there's a split
because for the euro for the europeans
there's a much higher cost and incentive
therefore to push
them to this war because
simply because they're paying a higher
price they don't want in afghanistan on
the continent their weapon stores have
been depleted from all these transfers
to ukraine the sanctions are hurting the
europeans much more not just this
temporary energy crisis and high
inflation but we'll also see that
european industries will no longer be
competitive on international markets as
all of these cheap russian energy and
metals are now exported to asia so the
production cost will therefore increase
dramatically in europe and
overall the europeans become more and
more dependent on the u.s as a result so
all these eu goals of strategic autonomy
will now collapse so i think you will
see more push now from for example the
germans the italians and the french to
to have some more diplomacy for to sit
down with the russians and you saw this
on display now with these three leaders
from the from italy germany and the
france going to keep asking to start
negotiations with russia meanwhile you
know thereafter you have johnson coming
from the uk saying this is not the right
time for peace and americans sending
heavier weapons so i i think that this
as the conflict continues to go the
wrong way for us i think it is
these divisions within the west it's
going to just become more and more
obvious ulrich how long before the
european electorate
begins to demand that their governments
ease the sanctions and pull back on this
war are people in europe prepared to
endure a winter of power cuts or
rationed energy supplies do you think
will it come to that
well if things continue like this there
is no other way than to restrict not
only industry but also heeding or
have other means that clearly show that
we are part of this war not as a party
of war but we are massively affected far
more than the united states
but it's very difficult to predict
because we don't have this one european
electorate we have very different
conditions in each and every member
state and we also have different
communication techniques by the more or
less popular leaders that also play a
role until
there is something like
a change of power within european union
member states at this point of course
german politicians would love to see a
diplomatic solution for this but public
opinion is still very strongly in
support
for actions of solidarity towards
ukraine and olaf schultz or emmanuel
at this point in time don't really have
much to fear
doug
i just want to give you an opportunity
to respond what glenn to what glenn was
saying about the us perhaps
uh
liking to keep this war going uh for the
moment uh and then i want to
ask you would the g20 do you think be as
solid in its support for ukraine and
condemnation of russia
as the g7 is
the broader you go the less support you
find for the u.s european position
of the top 10 population countries in
the world only one
is taking this position america you know
very notably not only china but india
have resisted indian purchases of
russian oil have skyrocketed very
dramatically but you go beyond that you
look at brazil you look at south africa
you look at indonesia i mean these are
countries that have not jumped on the
sanctions bandwagon and there's a lot of
reasons for that i mean the global south
is much more cynical about european and
american pretensions and morality i mean
the u.s believes in a rule-based order
except when it doesn't and then it
invades countries and occupies them even
if it's against international law and it
kills a lot of people
you know the president biden is talking
about human rights and about to make a
trip to saudi arabia to beg the saudis
who've killed hundreds of thousands of
people in yemen to provide more oil so
the us can sanction russia i mean the
the problem is those kinds of
inconsistencies really play out uh in
other countries whose view is much more
cynical they don't like the aggression i
mean so you know russia's clearly in the
wrong but they're also much more
skeptical of following leadership that
they frankly aren't quite so happy about
and the potential of indonesia inviting
russia to the the g20 meeting you know
adds a quite a complication exactly how
that would play out if it happens i
think
would be difficult for everyone involved
glenn while the g7 understandably sees
the war in ukraine as critical to to
global security what about
the rest of the world how supportive of
the g7's position are
asian african latin american countries
to what extent to to many countries
while sympathetic uh towards ukraine
simply have to put their own citizens
first
uh well that
kind of shows with the the numbers who's
joined in on these sanctions and well
it's pretty much restricted to nato
the rest of the world hasn't really
joined in on any of these sanctions
but i would agree with doug doesn't that
mean that
they support the the russian invasion of
ukraine uh by no means i think uh
most countries would condemn this
however
while there seems to be some consensus
around condemning it there's not that
much interest in punishing it yes
correctly because
it's not that not that many see there's
a moral authority of the west and also
they see more dubious interests behind
this in terms of knocking out the key
address area as opposed to standing up
for democracy as it was um but it's also
more recognition around the world that
that even though this is worth russia's
fault for invading that nato obviously
provoked
this to a great extent i mean this is
you hear this around the world and uh
you know not just sometimes in inside
nato as well with turkey now saying the
same thing you even heard the same from
the pope so you so this this seems to be
a large consensus that russia sorry
sorry that the nato provoked this but
then that russia shouldn't necessarily
have invaded for that reason um but but
but you also of course have this
economic interest behind it so it's for
the europeans for example to dictate to
the indians that they shouldn't buy any
russian oil or gas it seems
very provocative especially as the west
buys a russian oil and gas
but but overall i think they will look
after their own interest and one also
have to see these huge opportunities for
asia now because
european economies have been very
competitive because we've had access to
all these cheap russian energy metals
and now russia is as they're diverting
their entire economy towards the east
and they're preparing themselves for
permanent divorce with europe
the asian countries will become much
more competitive as russia is offering
even discounts to asia for their oil and
gas so so i think they will look after
their own interest and not get involved
in what is effectively a european
conflict
a 30 year old proxy war between nato and
russia which has now spilled in and
began to destroy ukraine
well rick has the g7 signaled clearly
enough that it understands the gravity
of the global commodity price
crisis and other
economic shocks linked to the war and
that they
will take realistic steps to address
them
well the question is what would
realistic steps be
and what has been said before
that
repeating the russian myth of nato is
threatening russia
doesn't make it any more credible
nato has no appetite to be involved in a
military conflict with the second
largest nuclear arsenal in the world
that makes no sense what threatened
russia
was the economic prosperity west of
russia if we compare ukraine and poland
then poland became four times richer by
joining the european union and if the
anti-ukraine would do the same thing
that would undermine the credibility of
an authoritarian regime in moscow
so if the west would
give in and say well actually we didn't
expect it to be so expensive and it also
has externalities on the rest of the
world we stop the sanctions what would
be the situation on the ground we could
possibly find something like a frozen
conflict but then both sides would try
as much as they can to strike back and
to win the upper hand that is not the
end of the conflict there is no military
solution in this conflict and it
needs more than
giving in of the one or the other side
this would only in my understanding be
a solution if other
heavyweights like china would step in
and do their contribution to stop it
doug the g7 statement said that the the
group will foster coordinated
initiatives that promote global food
security
to what extent should that
along with the rising price of fuel and
commodities
be their number one priority at least in
terms of maintaining
support for the war
in the rest of the world
well there are obvious humanitarian
reasons to do it set the war aside
you know the the lack of exports
particularly from ukraine in terms of
grain
are posing an extraordinary hardship on
poor countries that are least able to
deal with it the problem is again it's
not clear exactly what the west can do
that uh you know there have been
proposals to try to forcibly open
uh you know ports of ukraine in the
black sea
that would require number one
cooperation from turkey which is not at
all in my mind likely but second that
would be itself a potential casus bellai
and i think what we have to recognize
here the danger of this is is the longer
it goes on the more dangerous i think it
gets
which is you know for russia this is a
vital interest for russia this is an
existential interest
we don't have to think it should be but
it is in my opinion it's not for the
west so i think that russia and putin
are quite willing to risk and spend a
lot more and along the way ukraine is
the the primary victim i mean the world
bank figures the economy will be cut
roughly in half millions of people have
you know fled the country cities are
being reduced to ruin
so the longer we go the more dangerous
it could spread the more uh the russian
i mean the danger of a question of a new
use of nuclear weapons is one most
people assume won't happen nevertheless
to the extent they fear a loss i think
it becomes more dangerous so
the there's so much at stake and
certainly the issue of food is huge but
i don't know how we solve that absent
ending the war
that is unless one is willing to
forcibly try to open the black sea and
get the grain out the question is
otherwise are we as the west prepared to
share its resources to accept higher
food prices at a time of raging
inflation i don't think the biden
administration would for all of its
humanitarian rhetoric the democrats face
a potential disaster in november
by-elections
to kind of raise prices further to
appear to be giving away
american product and i think europe
faces the same difficulty
with energy prices rising at home
what can it do in terms of trying to
ease the food shortages abroad glenn
i've got less than a minute here just a
quick answer please bearing in mind what
what doug was saying that about russia
being pushed into a corner are the
sanctions against russia working are
they having the desired effect
well they're having some effect uh so
well so far that of course the the west
main goal was to destroy the russian
economy financial system and the ruble
well so far we see that the economy has
stabilized the financial system
stabilized and the ruble is much
stronger than it was before the war
however a lot of this punishment or the
pain of sanctions will probably come
later on so i think the worst of the
sanctions is yet to come for russia uh
but but that being said the point of
sanctions is to change the political
behavior and i don't see russia changing
his policies because for russia this is
deemed to be an existential threat nato
expansion towards the border it's said
for more than 20 years is an existential
threat so they're not going to give up
because of some
economic problems so they will probably
continue to fight this uh to the end and
uh
only exacerbating the conflict so i i i
it depends how i would define the
effectiveness of science
all right gentlemen we're out of time
many thanks indeed uh for being with us
today ulrich brookner doug bando and
glenn diesen
and thank you for watching don't forget
you can see the program again at any
time by going to the website at
aljazeera.com for further discussion
join us on our facebook page you'll find
that at facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story and you can join the
conversation on twitter our handle at aj
inside story from me adrian finnegan and
the team here in doha thanks for
watching i'll see you again bye for now
[Music]